[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
friend of the show
and a member of the phoenix suns the
former big ten national college player
of the year
frank kaminsky joining us on the program
how was the celebration there frank
it was pretty fun i mean when you show
up to an airport and there's 20
000 people there it's pretty wild
if you guys had to play a game the next
day after the celebration what kind of
condition
would everybody have been in oh we'd
have been fine
i mean there's still not a lot you can
do you know you get home late
maybe throw a couple beers back i don't
know a little celebration
nothing too crazy i saw you chugging a
beer in front of the crowd
yeah i mean sometimes when they start
chanting frank the tank and
things start getting a little wild you
know the people what they want sometimes
are you watching the bucks and hawks
absolutely
i can't get a playoffs this year i think
it's been great
do you can you watch as a fan are you
actually taking mental notes when you're
watching
i can't watch as a fan know i i pay too
much attention i watch
too much film um study the game too much
to just
just watch casually when i start
watching i get really into it so
um yeah and especially knowing this is
for sure who we're going to be playing
one of those two teams um
you watch it even even closer there's
the moment when uh patrick beverly
pushes chris paul and you're right there
next to him
yeah like put us in real time of what
you're thinking
what do you see then what are you
thinking so
we obviously went on a run um you know
close-out game emotions are high
we didn't get the job done in phoenix
whatever
we came out we played well in the second
half of that game
obviously there was a lot of chirping a
lot of reviews a lot of things going on
back and forth in that game
chris hits a big shot you know chris is
the leader obviously emotions were high
um i run out like i always do i stand up
the whole game right now
run out like i always do just to you
know be a good teammate and
give people high fives and do stuff like
that i see
you know pat kind of get a little
frustrated and some backstory
i've known pat for a long time we have
the same a major
uh same trainer in chicago um now he's
always been good to me always been a
good mentor
obviously it looked like he was going to
come up to say something to chris and
then he shoves him
and you know we always have this thing
with our team where it's it's don't
monty says it all the time and says just
don't react to the silliness
um and you can see our whole reaction it
was just
ensuring chris and then not making sure
we do something stupid because
we knew we were going to be advancing
and you and you don't want to have
something dumb happen
but obviously you know wish that
didn't happen you know i'm sure pat
definitely thinks that was
lapse of judgment on his part um but
that's when
the emotions are high and you're on a
stage like that you know things like
that can happen
how do you how do you hold back not
doing anything
um you know it's tough
you know obviously media has their
opinion on what i should
i know i've been doing
[Laughter]
but you know you don't especially you
know the position i'm in
you don't want to make things about
yourself obviously you want to defend
your teammate and do stuff like that but
um you know if i was out there just
throwing hay makers that'd be
a completely different story you know
may put someone in a situation that's
actually playing to get fined or
suspended or
have something stupid happen and you
know that would make me feel ten times
worse
i would have taken beverly though i
think if you guys squared off frank i
mean no offense i think you're too
you're you're too tall to be a boxer um
you know i do some i do a lot of boxing
in the summer i might surprise you i
have some reach
oh i know that but so you're saying if
if we had
you know these celebrities are fighting
now all the time
boxing match yeah you and patrick
beverly in the ring
what do you think um after the season
all right oh you take myself
all right paulie get get a hold of a
promoter
sorry i got frank the tank against uh
patrick beverly you know what for the
paul brothers
yeah and then the winner gets one of the
jake paul or logan paul
uh i always wanted to ask you this and
it's not just you but it's other players
that
when you have all the success in college
and then you go to the pros
and you're a high draft pick and now you
become a role player like
what that does to your ego or how do you
compartmentalize that that
you used to be the man at wisconsin and
a big you know the
college player of the year now all of a
sudden you're on the bench
yeah i i mean it's definitely difficult
um there's a lot to adjust to
but when you're on a team like this and
you're playing on the best team of your
career
um all that kind of takes a back burner
to the whole team's success you know
we have a great culture with our team
and obviously i'd love to be playing
um you know that's just the competitive
side of me you know every time we get
into a game i want to go out there and i
want to play
and i think that's the overwhelming
majority of the nba
you know five people can be on the court
at the time and not everybody's going to
play
and obviously there's going to be
situations where you have to keep
yourself ready you never know what can
happen
um you know and that's kind of kind of
been my mentality this year you know i
started off this season
at home by myself after getting waived
by the kings
and didn't really have anything and then
i got the call from phoenix that they
wanted to bring me back so
everything for me this year has been a
huge change in mentality um
you know i started off the season
literally nothing so
amazing the position uh going to the nba
finals gonna
going to be on a team and i've
contributed a point to the season
that i'm proud of where i am and i'm
proud of this team and i'm proud of what
we're doing
but also like how do you feel when the
kings let you go
um you know that was tough you know i
started out
free agency last year nobody was
calling wasn't options
took a non-guaranteed deal with
sacramento and they ended up waving me
after the preseason
and i mean
i'd say that's a low point for me um
but you know obviously did enough last
year with phoenix
and made enough good relationships that
they felt it good enough to bring me
back and like i said i felt like i've
contributed a lot of different points
throughout the season so that's
something i'm really proud of to start
mentally to start the season off with
nothing
and be in the position i'm in it's been
it's been great for me
well congratulations because that's
where you get down and then you wonder
okay
now what am i going to do with my life
nobody's nobody's coming you could have
a ring
in a couple of weeks pretty amazing
pretty amazing
it's it's it's wild and i definitely
knew coming into the season
that we were going to be in this
position you know our team was good
we had a lot of guys who were on the
rise and you know it's just something i
wanted to be a part of
like i said the culture here is amazing
well congrats there frank
and uh good luck with whoever you play
and hopefully you get uh an opportunity
and uh the next time somebody push
pushes uh chris paul
no don't do anything even though social
like social media roughed you up they're
like
come on like they're not the ones who
get suspended or have to pay a fine
exactly right yeah and
you know i'm not really you know i'd be
the first to say i'm not i'm not really
much of a fighter
so um you know i'm just happy we won
and we'll go with that i'm happy we won
and i'm happy chris is fine yeah we'll
go with that
hey uh thank you frank great to talk to
you again and uh good luck
thank you appreciate it that's uh frank
kaminsky